Now, are there actually better examples of ancestry composition? I mean.
>> Oh.
>> I feel like mine's pretty homogenous.
>> I'd love for you to pull up the, the results for a friend of mine Roy King.
>> Holy cow.
>> Who, now, Roy understands that his
ancestry traces to Europe, to Africa. and that
he has some Native American ancestry. And when
we look at his results here, we see,
look, even Chromosome one has multiple colors. It has
the red, the light blue, and a darker blue. And
the darker blue there refers to Ash, Ashkenazi Jewish ancestry.
And Roy knows that his father's father was, was Jewish.
>> Mm-hm.
>> And so, if we go back to map view.
>> we'll see that, about getting
close to a quarter of Roy's ancestry traces back to the
Ashkenazi Jewish population. And that fits with his, one of his
grandfathers being Ashkenazi Jewish. And if we look at the rest
of his ancestry, almost half of this is back to sub-saharan Africa.
[CROSSTALK]
The red ring here, and the rest traces back to
Northern Europe, specifically Britan and Ireland. Now, what is really
cool is that we have these bars right here. And
if we look over, if you click on a native american.
>> Mm-hm.
>> So those orange and deep red bars refer
to parts of the genome that trace back to
Native Americans. And and,
intriguingly Roy King knows that on his mother's side,
he has ancestors, acreek and Chocta ancestors. So that is a
showing up in his DNA. So basically you know, his understanding of
where his ancestors come from really shows that very beautifully in his DNA.
>> Right, he has a much more interesting genetic background than I do.
>> Right.
>> From many different parts of the world.
>> And that is important. Even when we go to look at the health
results, the health reports are all done
in the context of a particular population.
So, it's very important to kind of be clear on the ancestral background of,
of someone as we go to look at the other parts of their results.
>> Great.